hello everyone and thank you for coming
to my talk
my name is owen bisset and i'm a postdoc
at the institute for bioscience and
biotechnology research
which is a joint institute between the
university of maryland and the national
institutes of standards and technology
nist
i'd like to thank the event organizers
for inviting me to come give this talk
the title for today will be structural
fingerprinting of short oligonucleotide
therapeutics by high resolution solution
nmr spectroscopy
by the end of this talk i hope that
everyone will understand how nmr spectra
can be used as structural fingerprints
of short oligonucleotide therapeutics
and to understand how these methods can
be applied to a variety of structural
features including both native and
non-native chemistries and i'll get in a
little later into what that is
short oligonucleotide therapeutics are
an emerging class of biopharmaceuticals
to treat a wide variety of diseases
including those that are inaccessible to
current protein based and small molecule
based approaches
as you can see here the first
short oligonucleotide drug
approved by the fda occurred in 1998
and since then we've seen an increase in
the number of uh short oligonucleotide
drugs that are being approved
generally
short oligonucleotide drugs are either
antisense oligonucleotides or asos or
short interfering rnas sirnas the
exception being machine here which is
anaptomer
almost all asos
silence gene expression via rna
h-dependent degradation whereas the
s-i-rnas use the rna interference
pathway
one of the main hurdles
in developing these short-legged
nucleotides into therapeutics
are due to
overcoming their poor pharmacological
properties
so nucleic acids are inherently unstable
so drug development
drug development requires overcoming
their inherent instability and also
aiding in their delivery to target
organs
in terms of stability uh
changes in formulation conditions
including the ph salinity and oligocor
concentration all need to be optimized
but that will only get you so far uh
a lot of chemical modifications are
actually introduced into these molecules
so shown on the right is a short is a
residue from a short living nucleotide
therapeutic
and modifications are done uh at the
backbone so these include phosphorous
thyroid linkages the sugar region
two primo methyls and two prime fluoros
are often added at the two prime
position to render the reactive hydroxyl
group uh inert
uh you don't see these as often but you
can also have base modifications
including 5-methylcytodene
and in some instances entirely different
chemistries are used such as
phosphodamide morpholinos
and peptide nucleic acids
so really all these chemical
modifications are added to kind of
increase the stability
of the oligonucleotide so that it won't
be
degraded once it enters the body
the second
property that needs to be improved are
the drug delivery
won't i won't be discussing this very
much in this talk but
common techniques involve using lip and
nanoparticles or an acetylgalactosamine
conjugation
so there are plenty of different areas
uh during the drug manufacturing and
distribution process where
impurities can be generated
common techniques cur current analytical
techniques to
characterize the purity
and identity of
short oligonucleotides include mass
spectrometry and liquid chromatography
but these uh oligonucleotides can
undergo a variety of different
degradation pathways including deep
urination which is shown on the right
in this
case a adenine or guanine base is
removed and that leaves an a basic site
these are considered
harmful
due to the great measures the body goes
through to actually resolve these a
basic sites
other examples include hydrolytic
cleavage so the oligonucleotide is
broken up into smaller units uh
desulfurization so the phosphorous
thyroids
lose their sulform and get replaced with
oxygen you can also have different
cross-linking reactions
and deamination
so all of these
different degradation pathways can lead
to potentially harmful
impurities
and if they're not harmful they at least
would lower the drug efficacy
therefore techniques are needed to
not only
identify the impurities but also
determine the level of impurity
solution nmr is a high-resolution
structural technique that
provides
information on short-lived nucleotides
under full formulation conditions and
these methods could nicely complement
current mass spec and
liquid chromatography based approaches
so shown on the left in a is a sirna
and if we highlight all of the hydrogens
shown in b you can see that these are
very well dispersed throughout the
entire molecule
and all of these hydrogens are
readily
accessible via nmr techniques
so for each hydrogen atom so there's in
panel b a purple box around one of the
hydrogens
you get a particular signal in an nmr
spectra shown in c
so the chemical shift is along the x and
this provides information on the local
chemical environment and hence structure
surrounding that
hydrogen and the intensity of that
signal conveys information on
dynamics
so if you collect these types of
measurements throughout the entire
molecule you get an overall picture
of the structure and dynamic
of the
oligonucleotide
so as our group has demonstrated with
monoclonal antibodies nmr data can be
used as inputs
for chemometric analysis to determine
subtle changes in structure and purity
the goal of my project is to extend
these methods from monoclonal antibodies
into short oligonucleotide therapeutics
to aid in the development of our nmr
methods
we developed a model s i rna
shown here
for nmr benchmarking purposes
the model sign rna is modeled after
currently fda approved drugs and
includes a lot of the chemical
modifications
that are found
class including two primo methyls two
prime fluoros
and phosphothyroid linkages
we also have a randomly generated
sequence to remove any sequence bias
and it's capped with terminal gc base
pairs for stability
this sr model s iron is also prepared at
natural isotopic abundance to match the
conditions in which these drugs are
synthesized and it's formulated in a
buffer
closely matching those of other
fda approved therapeutics
within the model sir a you have both
what we call native and non-native
chemistry so the native chemistries uh
include
your bases like
adenosine guanosine
uridine and cytobean which are found in
all rnas or
in some dnas but then we also have
non-native chemistries and these include
uh bases like 5-fluorouridine
as well as some of the modified sugars
like 2-prime fluoro and 2-primal methyl
and you also have non-native chemistries
at the backbone regions such as
phospholiphthylates
so initially i'll discuss 1d nmr
fingerprints so these methods report on
a particular type of atom so shown here
we have
all the hydrogens so those are proton
nmr
and b you have all the phosphorus
and then in c you have all the fluorines
and as you can see these nuclei are
dispersed throughout the molecule in
varying degrees
the hydrogens are found throughout
whereas the phosphoruses are found along
the backbone
and then the fluorines are kind of
sprinkled in throughout the molecule
at the sites of either 5-4 u or 2-prime
floral modification
so the first
data i'll show you is from the
1d proton nmr and as you can see
these spectra are rather complex
this is due to the over 400 hydrogens
that are actually located within the sir
and a
which is shown in a so each one of those
hydrogens potentially gives rise to a
signal
and
there is only a limited amount of space
in chemical shift over which all of
those signals can resonate so in this
case it's about 15 ppm
so we can kind of break up the different
regions into belonging to a particular
class for instance around
1 to 2 ppm we have the methyl h7s
within you know the the one to
nine ppm range it's very hard to assign
these
or uh determine much about them from
just a simple 1d proton experiment the
exception being the amino region which
is boxed and uh
kind of expanded
around the 12 to 14 ppm range
these signals report on hydrogen bonding
so in the event of a base pair the amino
proton is protected from solvent
exchange and therefore gives rise to a
detectable signal whereas in the absence
of base pairing these signals broaden
beyond detection
so essentially each peak represents a
single hydrogen bond and one thing
you'll notice is we have numbers above
all of these signals
and these represent assignments so in
contrast to our previous work with mobs
which are these very large very complex
proteins
the relative simplicity
simplicity of the sir and a therapeutics
allows for their chemical shift
assignment which adds
a new level of detail so basically
atomic level insight
into the srna
which is very nice
another 1d experiment we can do is a
phosphorus measurement so
an a is the sirna with all of its
phosphorus is shown as spheres
and as you can see we have two kind of
clusters that show up in the 1d
phosphorus experiment
we have a group of signals around 0ppm
these correspond to the phosphates so
phosphorus bound to oxygen
and around 60 ppm we have the
phosphorous thyroids
so we can see that there's a very large
separation in chemical shift between the
phosphothioids and the phosphates
however within each group a lot of the
signals are kind of piled on top of each
other making it very hard to
learn much about them
with the phosphor thyroids so remember
that each one of these phosphorthiolates
can be in one of two diastereomers
either the rp or the sp configuration
and as it turns out the different
diastereomers resonate in different
windows
which is shown in b so even though this
region is rather cluttered
we can actually
uh
pick out the different diastereomers and
this kind of 1d spectra serves as
kind of a fingerprint for the overall
distribution of the different
diastereomers
within the oligonucleotide sample and
can therefore help in ensuring batch to
batch reproducibility
the last 1d measurement i'll show you is
for the
fluorine
spectrum is the fluorine spectra so
these are probably the most uh
simplified spectrum
due to the fewer number of fluorines
than phosphorus and hydrogen
and as you can see here both the five
fluorous and the two prime floors they
resonate in distinct chemical shift
regions and we're able to assign these
so even though there are fewer fluorines
compared to the hydrogens and the
phosphoruses
due to their distribution throughout the
oligonucleotide
they actually capture a lot of the
structure of the olympia
so in conclusion the 1d nmr fingerprints
provide a rapid initial samp assessment
of the sample quality but are relatively
low resolution
these experiments can be acquired with
in about 30 seconds as is the case with
the 1d proton measurements
the phosphorus and the fluorine
measurements can be completed in about
five minutes so really they're rather
rapid
kind of methods
one way we can improve the resolution
and their is by extending
the 1d fingerprint into a second
dimension so shown here
in a is the sirna in b we have all the
hydrogens
shown
and what we can do within a 2d nmr
measurement is now select only the
hydrogens that are attached to a
particular heteroatom
which in this case is going to be
nitrogen
and as you can see that therefore cuts
down the number the total number of
hydrogens that we're looking at now
we're only looking at hydrogens that are
bound to nitrogen
for those of you that are unfamiliar
with what a 2d nmr data set looks like
this
little schematic should help out
so here in a we have the sirna with all
the proton nitrogen pairs labeled
each one of those proton nitrogens
is going to give a signal
that's going to look like something in b
so
just like with the 1d measurement we
have the proton chemical shift along the
x
but now along y we have the heteroatom
chemical shift so in this case
n15
and then kind of in the third dimension
coming out of the page
in the z direction this is your
intensity
so just like a 1d measurement a 2d
correlation has information on
the local chemical structure via the
chemical shifts of the two
atoms the proton and the nitrogen but it
all and it also has information on
dynamics
and that's
the
intensity
in the
sir rnas there are several uh
both native and non-native chemistry
that can act as nmr probes
so you have the proton nitrogen
correlations these include
the aminos so these are involved in base
pairing
you can also have a long-range aromatic
proton nitrogen experiment
and then you also have proton carbon and
these come in a variety of different
versions so you have your aromatics
methyls two primal methyls and
deoxyribose and you can select the
different correlations by tuning the
scalar coupling between
the hydrogen and its
and the heteroatom
we also have
proton fluorine correlations that are
possible with these modified oligos
as well as proton phosphorus
correlations which i will not really
discuss in this talk
so here is a 2d amino proton nitrogen
experiment and as you can see
it's similar to the 1d amino spectrum
this defines the overall secondary
structure of the
nucleotide
what's nice about the 2d version though
is now you have your
you or
5 floor u signals separated from the g
signals by the nitrogen chemical shift
so you'll see at the top around 145 to
150 ppm all the g amino signals resonate
and then around 160 to 165 ppm in the
nitrogen dimension this is where all the
use
and fluorous resonate
so this is a very nice experiment and it
once again each signal corresponds to a
particular
base pair
one of the limitations of this method
though
is that you need to be at relatively
cool temperatures and
slightly acidic buffers in order to
ensure that the exchange rate of those
immunoprotons is low and therefore you
get decent signals
one way to bypass that is to do a
so-called long-range proton nitrogen
experiment in which case the adenine h2s
are correlated to the nitrogen n1 and
m3s
and the resulting spectra is shown here
for each a we have
each a in the sequence you get
signals for each of those and what's
nice about this once again is that you
don't need
cool temperatures and you don't need
acidic buffer conditions to get really
good data
one of the main limitations with the
proton nitrogen experiments are the
relatively long experiment times which
range from half a day for the amino
region
to one and a half days for this long
range proton nitrogen experiment
as shown here is a 2d aromatic proton
carbon spectra and this provides
information on base stacking
so this
the proton carbon correlations report on
both base paired and unbase paired
regions
and they are unaffected by solvent
exchange unlike the amino proton
nitrogen correlations
as you can see for our model s i rna we
have three distinct regions defined by
the carbon uh chemical shift
so up at the top of the spectrum you
have all the five floor uracils
uh in the middle you have the adenine
guanine
cytodine uridine and thymodine
aromatic
proton carbon correlations and at the
bottom you have all the
adenine h2c2 correlations
what we can also do with proton carbon
experiments is we can look at some of
the
non-native chemistry so shown here is
the
two primal methyl
spectra
normally in nucleic acids in particular
rnas the sugar regions are relatively
inaccessible by nmr due to the close
proximity of these signals to the water
resonance
but with these modifications you're
actually able to
shift a lot of these resonances far
enough away from the water that
uh the the signals are relatively
unprepared by the water suppression and
shown here as an example these are the
protons carbons from the two primal
methyl region
we can also do a
fluorine detected
fluorine proton measurement
and
once again uh
this is due to the non-native
chemistries of the short oligonucleotide
therapeutics that we can actually use
this technique and what's really nice
about fluorine is that it is virtually
background free and that none of the
excipients or
buffers contain fluorine so the only
signals that you'll see here
are actually from the
model sir a
and so these are very nice correlations
to have
all right so in conclusion the 2d nmr
methods they offer improvements in
resolution and selectivity
but they come at the cost of a slightly
longer experiment time so in the case of
the proton nitrogen correlations
these experiments tend to take around
half a day to one and a half days
the proton carbon correlations can be
acquired in as little as an hour for the
two primal methyl region
and as long as four hours for the
aromatic region
and then the hf correlations these can
take
probably around
four to eight hours and the same thing
for the proton phosphorus correlations
okay so all the data i've shown so far
has been on our model si rna what do
these data actually look like on a
fda-approved
drug
so to answer that we have a simulated
sir a drug product
give us siren which is shown here
zero siren contains a lot of the same
chemical modifications that were
represented in the model si rna
including two prime
o methyls and two prime fluoros and
phosphorous thyroid linkages
uh an additional uh
feature of gibbous iron is that it
contains this l96
down mac ligand that's conjugated at the
three prime end of the send strand and
this is to aid in drug delivery
so this
l96 ligand
is is unique to give osiris
in comparison to the model sir rna
shown here are the 1d nmr fingerprints
of give oscar and as you can see they
report on a variety of structural
features both at the base in the case of
the amino proton region the sugar as
shown here with the two prime fluoros in
the backbone
i'm showing both the phosphate and the
phosphorous thyroids
the 2d nmr data set
that i've i'm showing here these are the
amino correlations and as you can see
everything is nicely
resolved you have to use
resonating around 160 to 165 ppm in the
nitrogen chemical shift
and all the g's resonate around 145 to
150 ppm in the nitrogen chemical shift
and here we have a proton carbon uh
fingerprint this is actually of the
galmac ligand
so this is unique to
gilos siren in comparison to the model
si rna
so we're actually able to get a
fingerprint of that
galmac ligand
so in conclusion
i hope i've convinced everyone that nmr
spectra can serve as structural
fingerprints of oligonucleotide
therapeutics
one of the
great things about this class of
molecules are that their relative
simplicity
allows for their chemical shift
assignment
which is something that's lacking in
a lot of the monoclonal antibody work
just due to their large size and
complexity
these nmr methods can be tailored to
report on both native and non-native
chemistries
and based on
their distribution throughout the whole
oligonucleotide they provide
high resolution information on structure
and dynamics
the structure of the nucleotides is
encoded in their peak positions and
intensities all of which can be
leveraged through chemometric analysis
to detect subtle perturbations and
structures
and stability
and this work we hope will
be able to
aid in the drug development and
distribution process
here are a brief list of references
should anyone want to read more
and with that i'd like to thank the
event organizers as well as my
two mentors here at ibbr dr
robert brunson and dr john marino
i'd also like to thank some of our
collaborators so dr jace jones and anne
tran at
university of maryland uh baltimore for
their uh
complementary mass spec
work on this project and also dr
christina braganzo
who's done a lot of
computational work to
help out with this project
and with that i'd be happy to answer any
questions you may have for me thank you